raketenangriffe in nahost gehen weiter
und die gewalt zwischen arabischen und
jüdischen israelis nimmt zu kritik an
corinna lockerungen gesundheitsminister
sparen schreibt an die länder und warnt
vor risiken
whatsapp endet nutzungsbedingungen
experten kritisieren die weitergabe von
daten an den mutterkonzern facebook
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten heute ist norbert
könig dafür den samstagsmarkt schon
genommen
es ist die bisher schwerste eskalation
des israelisch-palästinensischen
konflikt seit sieben jahren
seit montag feiert die radikalislamische
hamas raketen aus dem gazastreifen nach
israel israelische bomben richten in
gaza verheerende zerstörungen an
tote gibt es auf beiden seiten heute
traf es auch ein hochhaus im
gazastreifen in dem internationale
medien ihre büros hatten nicht nur mit
bomben und raketen eskaliert der
konflikt zwischen israelischem militär
und palästinensische hamas ausgetragen
wird er auch auf den straßen in israels
städten der zweiten front des konflikts
kommt es weiter zu auseinandersetzungen
zwischen arabischen und jüdischen
israelis die immer öfter in brutalster
gewalt ausarten
so auch in jaffa einem viertel der
küstenmetropole tel aviv michael
bewerunge berichtet
es ist ein heimtückischer anschlag zwei
gewalttäter werfen molotow-cocktails in
die wohnung einer arabischen familie in
jaffa zwei schlafende kinder erleiden
schwere verbrennungen
die geschockten anwohner protestieren
friedlich
wir sind nicht bereit den angriff auf
diese kinder und unsere häuser zu
akzeptieren
wir sind hier um gemeinsam laut zu sagen
nein zur gewalt in vielen anderen
israelischen städten kam es zu krawallen
bei cesar erbauten arabische
demonstranten straßensperren auf und
lieferten sich kämpfe mit der polizei
zur gleichen zeit setzt die hamas den
wahllosen beschuss der israelischen
zivilbevölkerung fort heute mit mehreren
angriffen auf tel aviv und die
angrenzenden orte eine rakete schlägt in
ramat gan ein und tötete einen mann
ich habe zwei jahre in der armee gedient
und weiß wie raketen sich anhören ich
hatte furchtbare angst aber gott stand
uns bei es war furchtbar furchtbar
auch die israelische luftwaffe setzte
ihre angriffe fort mit vorankündigung
wurde dieses gebäude zerstört darin
pressebüros aber auch hamas soll dort
militärische einrichtungen betrieben
haben im westjordanland liefern sich
palästinenser straßenkämpfe mit
israelischen soldaten wie hier nach
ramallah die palästinenser begehen heute
den nakba-tag der an flucht und
vertreibung nach der gründung israels
1948 erinnert
gestern traf us sondergesandte hdmi in
israel ein er soll mit den
kriegsparteien über einen
waffenstillstand verhandeln ja in israel
ist michael b warum für uns und dort ist
wie gerade gehört ein amerikanischer
spitzendiplomat eingetroffen um zu
vermitteln wird er dann etwas erreichen
können michael ja ganz aktuell hat sich
sogar präsident biden noch mal in einem
telefonat mit ministerpräsident
netanjahu in den konflikt eingeschaltet
meldungen nach risse offenbar not amused
auf den angriff auf dieses gebäude was
wir gesehen habe wo auch die
amerikanische agentur associated press
ihren sitz hatte und biden hat auch wohl
mit palästinenserpräsident abbas
gesprochen
ganz so einfach wird es mit einem
waffenstillstand trotzdem nicht die
hamas hat ja ihre kriegsziele längst
erreicht sie hat gezeigt auch heute
wieder dass sie alle großen städte in
israel erreichen kann
und sie hat erreicht dass sich ein
großer teil der arabischen israelis mit
ihrer radikalen politik solidarisiert
aber israel hat genau das gegenteil gibt
ziel
israel will unter beweis stellen und
auch sicherstellen dass in zukunft oder
in naher zukunft nicht mehr so schnell
diese geballte raketen macht auf sie auf
israel herunter prasseln kann
vielen dank für die einordnung michael
bewerunge in tel aviv
der konflikt im nahen osten spiegelt
sich auch bei uns wieder demonstrierten
tausende in deutschen städten gegen die
gewalt anlass für viele
pro-palästinensische demonstrationen
heute war auch hier nakba der sogenannte
tag der katastrophe
größere demonstrationen fanden in
frankfurt und berlin statt susanna
santina
antisemitismus hat man in den
vergangenen tagen auf einigen
demonstrationen erlebt in berlin kam es
vereinzelt zu ausschreitungen
es gab mehrere verletzte und festnahmen
in frankfurt zeigte sich bei den
demonstranten vor allem sehr viel wut
über die israelische regierung ihre
siedlungspolitik
wir stören dass wir die al-aksa-moschee
schützen rufen sie wir haben nichts
gegen juden nur dagegen eine art rica
überhaupt nichts das gibt nur und kriege
dass die sofort aufhört israelis die
beschützen uns nicht nein
sehen sie sich in what was passiert
sehen sie sich in japan was passiert für
ein verbot der demonstration hatte sich
die jüdische gemeinde ausgesprochen weil
die veranstalter zur vernichtung israels
aufgerufen hätten
man sei schockiert über den
unverhohlenen antisemitismus auf den
demos in den letzten tagen und wir
fordern von der politik und von der
polizei hartes und entschlossenes
durchgreifen
wir brauchen in diesen für uns schweren
zeiten nicht nur die solidarität der
politik sondern die solidarität der
gesamten gesellschaft antisemitismus
erleben die spieler von makkabi
frankfurt sehr oft auch wenn hier jeder
mitspielen könne egal welcher
nationalität oder religion
es ist ein jüdischer fußball verein und
die spieler würden immer wieder
beschimpft scheuch hat man vergessen zu
vergasen bis hin zu zittern juden trikot
aus und dann auch handgreiflichkeiten
direkt nach dem spiel oder bis hin zu
messerattacken auch das habe ich schon
gespürt
der wachsende antisemitismus wurde auch
auf einer demonstration in berlin
angeprangert ein pro israelisches
bündnis forderte außerdem das ende des
raketenbeschusses aus dem gazastreifen
der krieg im nahen osten bewegt auch
heute viele menschen in deutschland auch
in mehreren städten europas haben sich
tausende menschen zu pro
palästinensischen demonstrationen
zusammengefunden darunter london und
madrid
in paris kam es neben friedlichen
protest auch zu ausschreitungen
die einsatzkräfte setzten tränengas und
wasserwerfer gegen randalierende 1
die demonstration war zuvor auf
anweisung des innenministeriums
untersagt worden da man die gefahr von
störungen der öffentlichen ordnung
befürchtete unser nächstes thema coruna
da geht die zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland weiter zurück das robert
koch institut registrierte 7 1894 neue
fälle das sind 7791 weniger als vor
einer woche
177 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus
die bundesweite weite sieben tage
incidents singt weiter auf jetzt 87,3 in
immer mehr regionen in deutschland
entspannt sich das infektionsgeschehen
also schauen wir uns das genau an
etwa zwei drittel der landkreise und
kreisfreien städte liegen aktuell unter
der hundertermarke dort fällt die
bundesweite notbremse wohl in den
nächsten tagen weg oder sie gilt bereits
nicht mehr
und das bedeutet jetzt greifen die
regeln der bundesländer die zum teil
deutliche lockerung erlauben volker
check mit dem beispiel baden württemberg
für einen schnellen start heute kam die
neue krone verordnung des landes baden
württemberg zu spät aber kommenden
mittwoch will christoph glück vom
gasthof zum roten bären in freiburg
öffnen 80 frisch getestete gäste genesen
und geimpfte haben platz in den
innenräumen sieben monate kroner
zwangsschließung jetzt liegt der
inzidenz wert bei 69,2 und die außen und
innen gastronomie öffnen gleichzeitig
das ist ein novum und das gibt es in
keinem anderen bundesland und deswegen
sehe ich das erstmal positiv und ich
glaube wir werden das auch wieder
positiv umsetzen können das sieht der
bundesgesundheitsminister ganz anders in
einem brief an die gesundheitsminister
der länder schreibt jens spahn bei
incidents werten von 50 bis 100 müsse
die innen gastronomie unbedingt
geschlossen bleiben
wenn zu viel zu schnell gelockert wird
und die gegenseitige vorsicht nachlässt
bestehen enorme risiken für erneut stark
steigende infektionszahlen
was es unbedingt zu vermeiden gilt ist
ein politischer wettlauf der lockerung
zumal im wahljahr die landesregierung in
stuttgart hält an den öffnungen fest bei
uns geht halt das personal dann in die
nachbarstaaten die schon bessere und
mehr öffnung haben und das müssen wir
verhindern weil es einfach auch ein
notwendiger teil des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalts ist diese branche am leben
zu halten
in den nächsten wochen werden mehr
länder ihren eigenen weg suchen bei
einer inzidenz von 100 übernimmt der
bund dann wieder das kommando
mit der bundes notbremse die fdp hat
ihren digitalen bundesparteitag
fortgesetzt im mittelpunkt heute stand
das programm für die bundestagswahl
darin enthaltenen forderungen nach
steuersenkungen und entbürokratisierung
der neu gewählte generalsekretär volker
wissing lehnte neben steuererhöhungen
auch eine weitere verschuldung zur
bewältigung der krone pandemie ab auch
staatliche vorgaben etwa bei der
klimapolitik seien nicht zielführend
können die kirchen die menschen noch
erreichen nein sagen viele kritiker
schaut hin das motto des diesjährigen
ökumenischen kirchentags in frankfurt
kommt also nicht von ungefähr wir wollen
hinschauen sagt kirchentagspräsidentin
limberg dahin wo es wehtut dahin wo wir
heilen und handeln können die
missbrauchsskandale bei den kirchen
corona pandemie oder klimawandel themen
und herausforderungen gibt es viele
denken klinge aus diesem studio hat der
ökumenische kirchentag heute den ganzen
tag gesendet segens roboter inklusive in
diskussionen und videos ging es auch um
politische themen wie klima soziale
gerechtigkeit und die korona pannen
die kirche will sich einmischen wenn es
um klimawandel geht wenn es um soziale
gerechtigkeit geht wenn es um hunger auf
der welt geht wenn es um die überwindung
von gewalt geht wenn es auch um die
überwindung sexualisierter gewalt in der
kirche geht das sind wir gefragt aus
rund 100 digitalen angeboten konnten die
kirchentagsbesucher zu hause am computer
wählen mit dabei waren auch prominente
gesichter wie eckart von hirschhausen
mit einer bibelarbeit über das thema
macht und missbrauch wurde teilweise
heftig debattiert das bild das wir als
kirche derzeit abgeben ist nicht
besonders einladend wir haben große
schwierigkeiten
der missbrauch ist immer noch ein
aktuelles thema und muss bearbeitet
werden
wir sind bereit uns auch anschauen zu
lassen und kritisch anschauen zu lassen
viele gläubige wünschen sich bewegung
von den kirchen kirche muss dynamisch
sein und keine angst haben sich zu
verändern wir brauchen nur noch
ökumenische kirchentage in einer
gesellschaft die den großen schatz hat
dass sie sagt wir wollen integrieren
im moment werden in frankfurt besondere
gottesdienste gefeiert mit der
gegenseitigen einladung zur mahlfeier
unabhängig von der
religionszugehörigkeit ob beim online
shopping bei sozialen netzwerken oder
messenger diensten immer heißt es zuerst
klicken sie die datenschutzbestimmungen
aber wissen wir überhaupt im detail was
drin steht bei whatsapp gibt es jetzt
weitreichende änderungen und die sorgen
bei daten und verbraucherschützern für
heftige kritik nicht transparent zu
schwammig formuliert wenn ricken mit den
details so soll sie aussehen die neue
zukünftige whatsapp welt zumindest wenn
es nach mutterkonzern facebook geht
shoppen überall per chat damit das
einfach und schnell geht soll facebook
die geschäfte abwickeln und braucht
dafür die kommunikationsdaten von
whatsapp doch der dienst schreibt
nirgends in den neuen
nutzungsbedingungen wer genau
geschäftspartner sind und damit auch
nicht welche verbindungsdaten erfasst
werden
für hamburgs datenschutzbeauftragten ist
das zu undurchsichtig was hilft es dann
wenn man als nutzer
datenschutzbestimmungen akzeptieren muss
bei denen der das unternehmen sagt das
machen wir eigentlich gar nicht aber
sozusagen auf vorrat bereits akzeptiert
dass da alles mögliche mit passiert was
keiner so richtig sehen kann weil es
eine blackbox ist weil es intransparent
ist da haben wir ein problem
wohlgemerkt was die nutzer schreiben ist
verschlüsselt aber wann wer mit wem
schreibt soll whatsapp in zukunft
weitergeben dürfen an facebook das gilt
zwar offiziell nur für geschäftspartner
aber wer damit gemeint ist sagt das
unternehmen nicht datenschützer
befürchten dass auch vereine oder
hilfsorganisationen gemeint sein könnten
wenn jetzt jemand häufig beispielsweise
mit den anonymen alkoholikern spricht
oder mit dem kommuniziert dann kann ich
leben rückschlüsse auf den einzelnen
betroffenen vornehmen wird damit ein
problem hat hat immerhin noch etwas
bedenkzeit ab heute bekommen vz-nutzer
einen immer wiederkehrenden hinweis aufs
handy nach rund drei wochen ist der
dienst an gesperrt und lässt nur noch
anrufe durch dem nutzer bleibt dann nur
noch akzeptieren oder löschen
welche anbieter ist in puncto
datenschutz anders machen als whatsapp
können sie in der zdf- heute- app
nachlesen
hier finden sie einen überblick mit acht
alternativen zum chatten
china feiert einen weiteren meilenstein
seines raumfahrtprogramms gleich bei der
ersten marsmission ist ein raumschiff
modul sicher auf dem roten planeten
gelandet
an bord der rover zur umbenannt nach dem
chinesischen feuergott er soll unter
anderem nach spuren von wasser unter der
oberfläche suchen allein ist er nicht
auf dem mars schon seit februar ist der
us provinz unterwegs
der vorletzte spieltag der fußball
bundesliga lässt noch einige fragen
offen aber einen historischen moment hat
das heute schon gegeben aber robert
lewandowski hat schon heute den
tor-rekord von gerd müller eingestellt
mit einem verwandelten elfmeter in
freiburg kommt der pole jetzt genau wie
der bayern-torjäger vergangener zeiten
auf 40 treffer in einer saison ein
bisschen geärgert hat er sich
wahrscheinlich trotzdem nummer 41 und
damit den alleinigen rekord vor
passt lewandowski frei stehend auf der
torlinie die kollegen werden gewiss
alles dafür tun dass es im letzten spiel
gegen augsburg klappt war der mann auf
die feier in freiburg muss sich der
rekordmeister mit einem 2 2 begnügen
schalkes dritter saisonsieg das viel zu
breit dämpft frankfurter champions
league hoffnungen augsburg schafft den
klassenerhalt durch das 2 0 gegen werder
bremen auch die hertha bleibt drin 0 zu
0 gegen köln bielefeld muss zittern 1 2
1 gegen hoffenheim gladbach stuttgart 12
leverkusen union berlin 1 zu 1 am
sonntag mainz dortmund und leipzig
wolfsburg die drei hinter dem fc bayern
spielen erst morgen wolfsburg kann für
die champions league planen falls
dortmund in mainz gewinnt ist frankfurt
wohl raus aus der königsklasse und würde
mit leverkusen in der europa league
starten
mainz 05 feiert den klassenerhalt auf
dem sofa historisch nach nur sieben
punkten in der hinrunde einen krimi wird
zum dreikampf zwischen bielefeld bremen
und köln um klassenerhalt relegation und
direkten abstieg gemeinsam mit schalke
04 bayern münchen erreicht beim final
four in eigener halle das endspiel um
den deutschen basketball pokal in einem
dramatischen halbfinale gleichen die
münchner gegen kurz vor ende der
regulären spielzeit aus nach zweimaliger
verlängerung um sekunden vor schluss mit
der siegchance aber bayern gewinnt 114
102 der gegner im finale morgen
göttingen oder titelverteidiger berlin
patrick hausding sammelt weiter
medaillen bei der europameisterschaft
der wasserspringer in budapest heute gab
es gemeinsam mit timo bartl bronze im
synchronspringen vom zehn-meter-turm
tina punzel kann sich ebenfalls über
eine weitere em medaille freuen die
25-jährige aus dresdner vor wenigen
minuten gold und beim wettbewerb vom
drei meter brett gewonnen es ist ihre
dritte medaille bei diesen
europameisterschaften und eingetaucht
und die vierer staffel der deutschen
freiwasser schwimmerinnen und schwimmer
holt sich in budapest silber medaillen
umgehängt und auf der strecke fast alle
abgehängt 5 kilometer für jeden im team
also 1250 meter näher bei leonie beck
rob muffels und florian wellbrock
zeigen sich in guter form nur italien
ist nicht zu schlagen dauer rivale
gregorio paltrow schlägt zum dritten mal
bei dieser em als erster an
doppel-weltmeister wellbrock kann dank
guten finish die silbermedaille knapp
vor umgang retten
die wettkämpfe im luca sie gelten als
standortbestimmung vor den olympischen
spielen in tokio und das aktuelle
sportstudio 23 uhr mit schiedsrichter
manuel gräfe
ja und jetzt gehts ja auch noch etwas
sportlich weiter denn wir haben noch ein
wenig olympische stimmung für sie tokios
nachwuchs im skateboarden dürfte den für
olympia neu errichteten skatepark
einweihen
die mädchen und jungen testeten alle
hindernisse auf herz und nieren mit
starken flips und waghalsigen stunts die
disziplin auf vier rollen wird in diesem
jahr erstmals bei olympischen spielen
ausgetragen
der jugendliche auftakt hier ist schon
mal geglückt beim bäcker geht es nass
weiter mehr dazu gleich von özden terli
das war's für diesen samstag schön dass
sie dabei waren
das heute journal mit claus kleber nach
dalli dalli um 22 uhr 45 und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder um 19 uhr einen
gemütlichen abend noch
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter sehr wechselhaft
geht es in den nächsten tagen weiter
aber auch schon in der kommenden nacht
selbst überqueren uns immer wieder
regengebiete und dazu mit tiefs die auf
kühle luft ansaugen das nächste tief im
westen steht schon an und erreicht uns
dann morgen in der nacht schauen wir in
die kommende nacht da gibt es im süden
deutschlands regen bei vielen wolken
nach nornen ebenfalls regen teils mit
schauern aber ab und zu lockert es
durchaus mal auf und die temperaturen
sinken dazu auf vier grad an den alpen
sonst sind es sechs bis acht im osten
bis 10 grad
ja und morgen im tagesverlauf geht es
dann wieder zur sache von südwesten her
ziehen schauer und gewitter nach
nordosten
die können auch mal kräftiger sein
durchaus mit hagel und sturmböen
die höchsten temperaturen dazu im osten
bis 18 grad 13 grad gibt es im vogtland
oder an den alpen
wenig änderungen gibt es in den nächsten
tagen weiterhin schauer und gewitter am
montag vor allem im süden gewitter bei
12 bis 18 grad und am dienstag im norden
mal trocken damit ein schöner abend